ich habe plötzlich einen rufschaden das
wasser steigt in meinem keller hoch und
ich brauche schnell einen experten der
mir da hilft und ich gucke dann im
branchenbuch nach oder auch im internet
und gerade an eine firma die mich am
ende abzock die wollen tatsächlich 2000
euro für ein verstopftes rohr oder sogar
mehr
unsere leserin heidrun f aus
friedrichshafen sollte sogar 12.000 euro
bezahlen ein irrer fall wir schon mal
rein
schreck für heidrun f der keller der
83-jährigen in friedrichshafen in baden
württemberg stand unter wasser
der abfluss war verstopft die rentnerin
recherchierte im internet nach rohr
reinigungsunternehmen bekam dann von
einem callcenter die firma first
vermittelt monteure kamen dann auch und
wollten 12.000 euro für die reparatur
als die senioren das nicht zahlen konnte
wurde der betrag fast halbiert
df unterschrieb und zahlte 2000 euro per
kreditkarte an
der rest sollte vom konto abgebucht
werden eine böse falle der sohn der frau
stornierte alle abbuchungen rechtzeitig
die 2000 euro per kreditkarte sind aber
weg bild konnte die firma first nicht
erreichen unter der adresse gibt es nur
einen briefkasten der sohn will die
firma nun anzeigen wie viele andere
geprellte kunden auch ein prozess der
staatsanwaltschaft gießen gegen
verantwortliche eines rohr reinigungs
clans wurde erst vor kurzem verschoben
wegen der korona pandemie
dieser fall macht mich wirklich
wahnsinnig wütend wirklich eine arme
rentnerin wird da abgezockt die carmen
kreditkarten lesegerät an und haben dann
sofort sehr sehr viel geld abgebucht von
2000 euro und sollte am ende natürlich
noch teurer sein als champions das macht
doch wirklich fassungslos oder über
fassungslos und es macht auch wütend und
das ist auch jetzt nicht so ganz auf die
leichte schulter zu nehmen auch
strafrechtlich nicht denn wir haben hier
möglicherweise eine strafbarkeit wegen
betruges betrugsversuchs dann haben wir
eine mögliche strafbarkeit strafbarkeit
übrigens auch wegen strafbaren wuchers
es ist nämlich so wenn jemand in einer
notlage total übers ohr gehauen wird und
man muss beispielsweise so etwa den
doppelten preis am normalen zahlen dann
kann das wo ich sein und das ist
strafbar das wird also nicht nur dazu
dass der vertrag unwirksam und
anfechtbar ist sondern auch diese
strafbarkeit da sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche paar schuhe und
deswegen finde ich es auch richtig dass
die betroffene hier anzeige erstattet
hat weil einem strafrechtlich dem inter
nachgegangen und zivilrechtlich ist
immer ganz wichtig dass man nicht vor
ort bezahlt man sollte also der
drohkulisse und meistens wird vor ort
eine drohkulisse aufgebaut da stehen
dann zwei drei leute und die sagen du
musst jetzt bezahlen das ist ja
vereinbar
dem sollte man widerstehen wenn man es
alleine nicht kann polizei rufen und
dann später im überweisen dann kann man
nämlich die rechnung genau prüfen und
dann muss man auch ganz ehrlich sagen
jedes seriöse unternehmen möchte
ausdrücklich dass kunden die rechnungen
durch sehen
nur das bezahlen erst mal was eben
unstreitig ist über den rest kann man
dann diskutieren
aber das ist eigentlich seriöses
vorgehen und man merkt sofort wenn die
unternehmen schon vorkasse wollen bevor
sie überhaupt kommen so richtig also
bevor sie die tür überschreiten und dann
schon geld haben wollen und den rest
wenn sie die wohnung verlassen das ist
in aller regel ist das ein böses
alarmsignal
und da sollte man eher die finger von
lassen